[Music]
all righty hi everybody and thanks for
coming to this session my name is
Laurence Moroney I work as a developer
advocate on the Google brain team I'm
primarily focused on tensorflow machine
learning and AI I've just come from
another session so I'm doing
back-to-back sessions and if you were at
the previous session some of this
material you probably have seen already
so forgive me for the duplicate and
because I know there's a lot of folks
waiting outside so if we can kind of
shove up and like maybe if there's some
room for other folks to come in or if
you're outside and you can hear this
we're repeating this session on Thursday
morning so take a look and we'll see and
if you want to hear the session there's
a repeat of it being done on Thursday so
I'm here today to talk a little bit
about tensorflow and to introduce you to
tensorflow
but I always like to begin with the
question well what is AI anyway right
you know you're open you turn on the
news you open a newspaper you browse the
web and you see people talking about AI
and it's you know you probably see
pictures like these of like you know CGI
Androids or you know predicting the
future or maybe things that are even
worse and you read a lot of doom and
gloom
you know scaling from AI is taking our
jobs to AI is the next Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie you know and it's
it's all of these things and it's I find
that maybe we as an industry have done a
pretty bad job of explaining what AI
actually is we talk a lot about what it
does but we rarely talk about what it
actually is and particularly from a
programming perspective so actually a
quick question how many people here are
developers who write code ok a lot of
you cool so you're the right audience so
what is AI anyway I like to talk about
it in terms of writing code and I like
to talk about machine learning in
particular in terms of writing code so
say for example if I wanted to write an
application which is a classifier of
cats versus dogs okay how would you do
that being a coder we all write code
that's like if this then that while this
do that all these kind of things but how
would you do that for like a classifier
of cats versus dogs like say I give it
this image and this image is you know as
a human being you're going to take a
look at and you say that's a cat why do
you say that's a cat
probably some features on a do you
recognize that a very cat-like like the
pointy ears right so it go okay you look
at that and you say that it's a cat and
you think about that as a program where
you might say if has pointy ears then
cat you know but in order to get that
you have to process the image somehow
find where the ears are in the image
somehow and determine that they're
pointy somehow it's very complex very
hard to do but then I'll show you this
image okay is this a cat it's not right
it's a dog but it's got pointy ears and
as a result we go huh okay I can't just
say if has pointy ears then cat and then
I show this image and it's like okay
this is got really pointy ears okay you
know said a cat or is it some kind of
weird science fiction creature I don't
know it's got very strange ears to me
and so I go okay so like this is where
I'm confused as a developer okay it's
gonna be very hard for me to write all
the image processing and write all the
offends and all these kind of things to
figure out okay which is a dog in which
is a cat and then I go like okay there's
another feature of a dog that we all
know and it's like this alright so you
know if it's got a big long floppy
tongue like that it's probably a dog and
in my case I usually write the rule like
you know if it's currently plotting your
murder then it's a cats and if it'll of
you for the rest of your life then it's
likely to be a dog and then when I'm
like looking at image like this and
trying to classify them then I come up
with a beauty like this which to me is
this is what happens to with a Mogwai
when you feed them after midnight but
apparently it's a dog as well so but as
a programmer it's really really hard for
me to write some kind of an application
that would determine this okay like not
everybody needs to write an application
of cats versus dogs but maybe you do
need to write some kind of
classification application spam versus
not spam hot dog versus not hot dog for
Silicon Valley fans and you know that
can do you write these classifiers and
in traditional code that's very very
difficult because traditional code looks
like this right you've got your
classical programming you input the
rules to that and your rules are the
code that we all make our
bread-and-butter off of you know writing
Java or C++ or C sharp or Kotlin or
objective-c or Swift or how many other
languages there are out there you know
that's the rules that we writes and we
get usually in classical programming we
write rules we have data and out of that
comes answers so we write an application
with lots of rules in it to say it's
pointy ears it's a cat's you know
those kind of things but the idea is
that then there are a number of
scenarios that are really easy to do
with this but there are scenarios that
are practically impossible to do with
this you might be able to write a cat
vs. dog classifier but think about the
amount of code that you'd have to write
the amount of code that you'd have to
maintain and then suddenly you get
another picture of a creature and you
don't know if it's cat or a dog you
probably have to rewrite all your code
again it becomes infeasible and
difficult to do that now one of my
favorite things I wear a SmartWatch and
on my SmartWatch it has activity
detection it knows when I'm running it
knows when I'm walking and those when
I'm swimming or in my case sinking and
you know and it knows all of these
things based on it's been trained based
on data to say you know they the people
who built a SmartWatch took thousands
and thousands of people and said let's
make them walk and say this is what it
looks like when you're walking when
you're wearing a watch let's make them
run this is what it looks like when
you're running when you're wearing a
watch let's make them swim this is what
it looks like when you're swimming when
you're wearing a watch and to actually
train a system off of that so it changes
the rules completely so instead of you
inputting rules and inputting data and
getting out answers the concept of
machine learning and the whole
revolution of machine learning is very
simply you input answers any when put
data and you get out the rules so the
idea behind this one is you get lots and
lots of data to show something so for
example I get thousands and thousands of
images of cats and I say this is what a
cat looks like you know so the data are
the images the answer is me saying this
what a cat looks like same for dogs same
for Mogwai same for all these other
things or if I'm building a watch I get
lots and lots of data of people running
I get lots of nuts of paper
data of people walking and all of these
things and I train it and so as a result
it's opened up all these new scenarios
for types of applications that you can
build that would be very difficult to do
with if-then kind of rules you know some
of the early spam detectors use a lot of
if-then you know if the body contains
these particular words it's probably a
spam you know if it's sent to you BCC it
might be a spam if it's sent from
somebody in your contact list that's
probably not a spam all of these kind of
things and you could kind of get a good
spam detector with if-then rules but
what if I mean many of us received
thousands of emails a day and we
categorized spam not spam or what if
that's us giving the answers and
machine learn a machine learning
algorithm could take the data this is
what a spam looks like this is what a
not spam looks like and as a result you
end up getting vastly improved spam
filters because they're trained in that
way so then the question comes well how
do you train him
okay so just show the diagram again
first so it's like you know classical
programming machine learning very
different we're just flipping the axes
and the nice thing about flipping those
axes is that it's opening up new
scenarios that I thought and I think the
industry has shown were previously close
to being impossible so I'd like to use
an example and it's one thing that I've
been working on since I started on
machine learning and I've only been
working on this at Google for about six
months but the first project that I took
on when I was doing it was to take a
look at breast cancer data now if you
think about breast cancer data and in
this case the data set that I was
looking at for breast cancer data had
about 30 different data points for cells
in a biopsy around breast cancer and
these data points would be things for
example such as the size of the cell the
density of the cell the shape of it
things like that and it's like so with
these 30 different data points you could
conceivably write lots of offends you
know if it's above a certain size if
it's a certain like density if it's a
certain shape then there's an increased
likelihood of it being a breast cancer
cell and you do something that looks
like this right so like the red ones on
the right and malignant
big ones and malignant green ones are
benign you know wouldn't it be really
nice if it was that easy you know if X
is greater than 30 then its malignant
cells its benign but unfortunately it's
not that easy right because then if you
add a second axis to it it kind of looks
like this and you got a little bit of
overlap you know you can't just draw a
straight line down the middle and say if
X is greater than 30 but you could
probably draw a line like this and then
say okay you know the ones above and to
the right of the line are malignant and
the ones in below to the left of the
line are benign and if you remember your
high school geometry you know the
equation of a line y equals MX plus C
and if you can figure out what the M is
and you can figure out what the C is
then you can start saying ah now maybe I
can start making a decision about what's
malignant and what's benign this is
great and that line in machine learning
parlance is called a decision boundary
but this is the reality the data this is
what it looks like it's not really that
simple
so I've plotted this this is only three
dimensions that I'm plotting instead of
there were about 30 in the data set
and the three dimensions that imploding
are the two that I showed a moments ago
plus a third one is the actual size of
the cell so if you look closely the the
blob the size of the blob is
proportional to the size of the cell so
you see the ones over on the right are
really big and the ones over on the left
are really small so even just plotting
in three dimensions of data then we got
a lot of mixed-up data right in the
middle there so how do I draw a decision
boundary you know do I draw it something
like this where most of the ones on the
right are red and most of the ones on
the left are green you can't really do
that with something as important as
cancer right you know you just you just
can't depend on that type of thing so
and also if i zoom in and I start
looking okay of the axes here with a
smoothness compactness and the concavity
you know you can see even when i zoom in
it's not really that simple that you
know there are Reds amongst the greens
and there are greens amongst the Reds it
becomes very very difficult for me to
make a simple decision with an if this
then that type of algorithm so if I go
back to this and I think it starts
thinking about this in machine learning
terms instead of traditional programming
terms and I'm gonna say okay it's the
simplest example and I know this isn't
going to work because I'm only training
on one feature so when I say you know
when you do machine learning you
remember you pass in the data you pass
in the answers so when I'm talking about
features this is one of the aspects of
the cell I'm just gonna pick one of them
in this case it was the size and if I
only train on one I know it's gonna fail
but I just want to use this as an
example of how the process works so here
it's a case okay in the case of a neural
network I'm gonna say I have this if
then if it's greater than 30 it was
malignant if it's less than 30 then it's
benign well what if I created what I
call a layer in a neural network and the
idea of that layer is that it calculates
something called a weight and then the
weight if you remember y equals MX plus
C the weight is the M it's the slope of
the line but we only have one axis here
so it's even simpler so we'd say okay
when we think about this as a function
you know well we saw 18 was benign 17
was benign 13 was benign 31 35 and 39
were malignant
it's really easy for me to say okay and
my layer I'm gonna call a function
called relu reloj is a common function
used in machine learning and it
basically is the same as writing the
code if X is greater than zero then the
output is X otherwise the output is zero
okay the idea is it just allows you to
filter out negative values so I'm gonna
say here I'm gonna subtract 30 from the
radius and get the relative that greater
than zero is true zero is false and now
I can start going up I now have made
this decision I've created a really
simple network which isn't really a
neural network at all but I'm able to
say unlike the wait for this is one
because it's gonna work all the time so
what the answer is going to be 1 times
the relu of radius minus 30 you know
this is all the very mathy stuff that
goes on in a neural network
unfortunately you're not gonna need to
know most of this but I want to show
what's happening under the hood so then
if I go ok so my second one is like
here's a here it is in two axes and my
decision boundaries gonna look like this
as we showed earlier and we've y equals
MX plus C so in a neural network
parlance what's that going to look like
well I got two layers and these two
layers I'm gonna have one figure out my
am which is the slope of the line and
I'm gonna have one figure out my C and
my output is gonna be y equals MX plus C
so when I can figure out the M and I can
figure out the C or if a machine can
learn what the M is and a machine can
learn what the C is now the machine has
that decision boundary that it's figured
out for itself and me as a programmer I
don't need to write any code for that
it's figured it out for me so now I can
go okay what if I initialize it with a
couple of random values something like
this you know where m equals zero and C
equals five we can visualize that the
boundary looks like this but it's not a
very good one right there's a lot of you
know benign cells above the line that
are showing up as malignant it's not
horrible because you know you're gonna
tell somebody that they have cancer when
they don't which is not good but it's
not as horrible as telling them that
they don't have it when they do but we
go okay we can learn from this let's see
if we can do better so what happens then
in your neural network is it's gonna say
okay I'm gonna take that value draw that
line with those initial values I'm gonna
calculate which ones are right and which
ones were wrong and based off of that I
can figure out what my loss is and then
I'll have a function called a loss
optimizer and what all the loss
optimizer is is there's a bunch of
built-in mathematical functions that say
you know what when you lose this much
try tweaking your m to this and your C
to that and then see how much you lose
and if you lose less we're heading in
the right direction if you lose more
we're heading in the wrong direction so
let's week them the other way so those
kind of things 10
of Lodo's for you automatically all that
optimization all those lost functions so
typically I'll get my data and I'll test
that and I know the answers already to
this data so I'll keep going until I
have a very low loss so when I come up
with an AM and a see that works for all
of my data I now know that I've trained
a neural network to make a decision
based on the boundary so for example
maybe it goes to this and says okay I'm
gonna try this value and this is a
terrible value so even though my loss
value like my brains are great I have a
couple of mulignans here but I'm telling
the person they don't have cancer you
know so that's if I if I try it with M
equals zero and C equals 12 and you just
keep trying and the idea of a neural
network that's what it is the process of
training that we call it is just trying
and trying and trying different values
calculating the loss each time figuring
out what you're going to do to reduce
the loss the next time and then try that
value and keep going until you get a
decision boundary which gives you a very
low loss or a very high result now in
this case obviously with two dimensions
we say hey we're an M equals minus 1 and
C equals 20 we got a great decision
boundary but that was only two axes and
of course the real data looks like this
but the real data looks like this you
know in higher order math instead of
drawing a decision boundary like this
which is bad the reality is it's
possible for you to draw a decision
boundary through multiple higher level
dimensions like in this case five
dimensions of five signal or five
features but if you've got 30 features
it's possible for you to actually draw a
line across 30 dimensions with an
equation that's very similar to doing it
in two dimensions that we had here and
so I'm not a mathematician I can't
figure out that math for myself but
fortunately the process is exactly the
same as it was for the two dimensions
that I showed earlier on so you know we
have your layers you have your weights
and when you think about you have your
weights on those layers you're just
going to figure out what wait for this
value what wait for this value what wait
for this value will give me my output
I'll do my loss optimization on that and
like in this case I've got three layers
I could have 30 layers or I could have
more those kind of things and as a
result it will the loss optimizer feeds
back to the weights that feeds back
through and that psychical process that
I've mentioned is the process of
training a neural network so in reality
this ends up looking like in the case of
the breast cancer
you know you pull a biopsy on a cell a
doctor will pull the biopsy on the cell
and then that biopsy you know is used
the cell will be explored under a
microscope and then the features of that
cell will be extracted you know we're
gonna take a look at the radius of the
cell we're going to take a look at the
concavity of the cell I'm gonna take a
look at the size of the nucleus to color
things like that and those features are
then put into a database and then that
those features from that database are
then extracted into and fed into a
neural network you know we have an input
layer in the neural network we got a
number of neurons and we got fancy
diagrams like this but all that's going
on in that Network is that a constant
cycle going on going on going on trying
to find the weights that will give you
that line that you draw through a
multi-dimensional space that gives you
the optimum amount of values of one side
on the line and the optimum amount of
values on the other side of the line now
I do want to I always like to stress
here and then out of that you'll have
two neurons and the neurons will be an
estimation of whether the cell is
malignant or an estimation of the cell
is benign so it might you know you give
it a particular cell and it might say
hey this cell there's a 5% chance it's
malignant there's a 95% chance it's
benign I always say divine there I don't
know why and so the idea then is that
this is something that we want to build
as a tool that will help doctors not
replace doctors so the idea is think
about the amount of time that it would
take to explore this data to take a look
at something if you're doing it manually
but if you get enough samples and you've
trained those samples against ones that
have been labeled by a doctor that a
doctor says this is what a bad cell
looks like this is what a good cell
looks like then you can speed up
diagnosis so that's the idea of like how
a neural network actually works and how
that fits in then to the idea of
artificial intelligence is that you know
you if you think about an artificially
intelligent application is an
application that does everything it's
your user interface
it's your if-then code but it's also
taking advantage of machine learning it
may have a number of different models of
machine learning one for analyzing the
breast cancer one for maybe I don't know
analyzing the patient's ability to pay I
don't know all of these kind of models
so that you know it's hybrid code where
you've built models for making a
decision combined with code that you've
written yourself is your overall
artificially intelligent application
and then there's a process called deep
learning which is part of machine
learning and that's when you start
really getting into the deep neural
networks for classifying and for
understanding things my breast cancer
one could be either a traditional
machine learning or a deep learning I
haven't really gone that deep and
understanding the network behind that
yet I've only really just started
working on it but I like to use that as
an example to illustrate how the process
works so all of this is available
through what we call tensor flow tensor
flow is your programming API that allows
you to do these things this allows you
to design your neural network this
allows you to take your data and
structure it so it can be run through a
neural network and this allows you like
all those things that I mentioned like
those mathematical functions like for
loss optimization and all those kind of
things are built into tensor flow so you
don't have to be a mathematician to
figure out how to do them yourself it's
a case of you design your neural network
intensive flow and then once you've
designed your neural network you run
your code through your neural network
and you hope that it works a lot of it
of course you're gonna have to optimize
your network and it's a lot of just like
if you're writing Java code or C++ code
I would say okay for a particular task
what's better a for loop or a while loop
sometimes you got to write both and
figure out which it's the same kind of
thing with this you're going to design
your neural network based on your input
data train it with your data and then
you can optimize and optimize and
optimize to see what works so the goal
is that we've been building this in open
sourcing this to be a machine learning
plan machine learning platform that's
for everybody to solve real world
problems so we started using machine
learning many many years ago at Google
we've been constantly building
constantly refining it I mean there's
one thing that I joined Google five
years ago there's one thing that they
told me that when I first joined that I
thought was really funny particularly at
the time and that was that we have cafes
in Google that serve food to Googlers
and they actually have been using
machine learning for many years based on
people using the cafes and based on
wastage of food and that kind of thing
to predict how much food to cook and so
as a result that we they will overall
reduce the waste of your food and like
little things like that have been going
on internally for many many many years
and it's all of this learning all of
this code that we've been writing for
our own systems is what we've taken and
brought to the world as tensorflow which
is this machine learning platform for
everybody
so as a programmer the steps to build a
machine learning model they're a little
bit different than what you're used to
as a programmer you might get like a
design document or a specification and
then you decompose that and then you
write some code around that and maybe
you write something like throwaway
prototyping code and then I throw away
prototyping code you learn something
from that and you keep going you keep
iterating with machine learning it's
different but in some ways it's very
similar from the iterating part so the
first thing you need to do is gather
your data okay you've got lots of
different data sources that your data
might be in there's lots of different
ways that your data might be represented
let me give an example like in the
breast cancer that I've been talking
about there's the size of the cell say
that size of the cell might be a value
from ten to thirty an integer or a long
value from ten to thirty that's probably
not very good for me to train a neural
network I might want to normalize that
data where like the smallest cell is a
zero and the biggest one is a one so
I've got a span of data and then that
can be a little bit more intelligent
that I know the ones towards the bigger
end of the span are more likely to be
malignant and the ones towards the
smaller end are more likely to be benign
things like that that you got to gather
your data and then you've got to ingest
that data into the programming language
that you're using
most people when building with
tensorflow use Python but we've been
expanding tensorflow recently we've
added Swift and we've added JavaScript
recently and so think about the data
structures and the the ways of
representing data that are available in
those languages and you have to ingest
it into that but even further on one
extra step that you have to take is a
tensorflow developers we've got
something called TF data where the idea
is that say for example if you're a
Python developer and you're using numpy
that's great for you to be able to train
your models off of but it's not optimal
it's not optimized if you then take that
and convert that into TF data which then
converts that into tensors and the idea
of tensor flow is the concept tensors or
a mathematical construct and it's all
about flowing those tensors through your
neural network doing those calculations
and being optimized so your first step
gathering your data you take it you
stick it into your programming language
and then you optimize that using TF data
and so then the next part is you know
processing the data is choosing your
features and choosing your labels in the
case of the breast cancer that I've been
speaking about there were thirty
features I was able to train a network
that was just as good at predicting a
malignant or a benign
using only six features as I had from
one that was using 30 and the one that
used those six features took a fraction
of the time to train to give another
example uh the there was a there's a
common data set out there for house
prices in California that a lot of
people use for learning and machine
learning and one thing I learned when I
was playing with that one that I thought
was really interesting was that usually
when you're buying a house the number
one thing that dictates the price is the
number of bedrooms right a four bedroom
house costs more than the three bedroom
cost more than the two bedrooms
typically but when training and neural
networks actually predict house prices
the number of bedrooms had no impact you
know I trained a model and I got a
particular set of accuracy I trained it
by removing the number of bedrooms I got
the same accuracy but it was quicker to
train because often sometimes one piece
of data is hidden in another in this
case the number of bedrooms is hidden in
the size of the house four bedroom house
is bigger than a three bedrooms bed
bigger than a two bedroom and it was the
size of the house was the bigger signal
in determining the price of the house so
things like that is processing data
formulating it to optimize 4ml it's a
lot of trial and error and that's really
what we call data science then of course
there's training your model that's where
you're going to be writing a tensorflow
code I'll show some in a moment we're
designing your network you're
experimenting with it you're optimizing
it for accuracy and then finally and
probably most importantly is where do
you use your model so there are a number
of different places you can use it
there's a serving environment we've got
something called tense flow light
they'll allow you to run on a mobile
I'll demo that in a moment and then it's
a course of continually optimizing
improving and updating your code so
let's take a quick look first at
gathering data if we can switch the demo
machine so sorry before we switch to the
demo machine sorry go back to the slides
for a second my screen savers they're my
beautiful screen serve can we go back to
the slides so a very famous detective
Sherlock Holmes des said it's a capital
mistake to theorize before one has data
and unfortunately he's fictional but
he's also right and so getting good data
and training your system with good data
is very very important so gathering data
it's all about data science data is the
lifeblood of machine learning you know I
showed the diagram earlier on where it's
data in answers in rules out so you
really you know the the the job role of
data scientists has grown massively in
importance in the last few years and
this is the primary reason why
because you can write crap code that
will compile and still execute right you
know the programmer the really good
programmer is the one who writes the
really good code that becomes easy to
maintain that executes quickly and
doesn't have bugs in production it's the
same kind of thing in data it's
gathering your data you can train a
neural network that's going to work but
you could train it on all the wrong data
and training could take a long time and
be very expensive the model may not be
optimized so it ends up being your data
is the new code in many ways so one of
the things that you need to help you get
your data ready of course is good tools
so one of the tools that we have in
clouds that I like to use is bigquery so
the nice thing with bigquery is it gives
you this massive data warehouse if you
got tons and tons of data and my breast
cancer example I only had a few hundred
records or didn't need that but say
you're training off of millions of
Records big career is really great for
that because not only does it stored it
in a way that's easily accessible and
it's quick for you to access it also
allows you to do some analysis on your
data and then download it for example is
something like a CSV that you can then
turn into a training model and right now
even though CSV is quite primitive it's
the number one data format that's used
in a lot of machine learning so and now
can we switch to the demo machine please
and just to give a quick look at what
bigquery looks like you know I have a
query running here so there's a number
of public data sets that we've put into
bigquery and so these public data sets
and one of the one that I've been
playing with and I've been having a lot
of fun with us there's a baseball data
set you know so I love to play fantasy
baseball and I'm now giving away all of
my secrets of how I beat all my friends
our fantasy baseball because I've been
doing a lot of machine learning stuff
out of the baseball data set that's in
bigquery and Shh don't tell them and so
you know then the idea is like you know
bigquery this is a browser-based
interface I'm doing it as a live demo
now but so for example here I'm going to
search for pictures and I'm gonna search
for my third favorite baseball player
can anybody guess who it is from his
name or picture first name equals Felix
I'm a Seattle guy I'll give you cue clue
but I run a query and there you can see
it just took like one point two seconds
it's gone through the entire data set
this is just the standard query it's a
sequel query but it's given me the data
from that data set and because it's
sequel I can start doing interesting
things like that like normalizing it or
whatever or I could just take the data
and I can just
and then do all the fun normalization
stuff using tools or directly in Python
or whatever language I'm using to put it
into tensor flow so can we switch back
to the slides please so the next step
then is processing your data and
processing your data is a little bit
different than it would typically be
because of the how you sometimes need to
encode your data to make it understood
by a neural network so the first thing
that you do is I've mentioned earlier is
you know whatever your language specific
encoding is Python JavaScript array
Swift data all those kind of things take
a look at this URL censor float org
slash guide slash data sets that will
tell you the optimal ways to represent
your data in these languages and then
turn it into TF data which is a format
of data which is tensor based which is
then optimized for running in sense of
flow but more importantly is how you
think about your data and let me give
one example for your feature engineering
and this is unintuitive as a programmer
so say take for example I've got
something that's got four different
classes and my breast cancer was to
write malignant or benign but say I want
to classify guys something that's got
four different possible classes now as a
programmer I'd say okay if something has
got four possible options the optimal
way for me to store that it's probably
two bits right you know zero zero zero
one one zero one one you know or maybe
slightly less optimal is it's an integer
okay I'll put it as an integer so it's
gonna be zero one two or three but in
machine learning you actually use four
integers to store it you know when you
go this this seems crazy why would I use
four integers to store a value that
could be between zero and three so the
reason for this is that start thinking
in terms of we want to run
classification on something
remember we're giving it the data we're
giving it the answers and it's inferring
in the rules and giving us something out
so in this case I would say okay there's
going to be four neurons at the end of
the neural network and these four
neurons are going to give me a
percentage probability that it is what
it is like I don't know pick something
that there's four of I don't know soccer
teams in a group in the World Cup right
so what was it was England Belgium
Tunisia and South Saudi Arabia I think
we're in one group so imagine if I was
building a probability that these ones
are going to win that group in the World
Cup
now instead of it outputting like a zero
for
one for Belgium that kind of thing it's
a case of I have four neurons that are
gonna fire and I want this neuron to
fire if I'm predicting England to win I
want this neuron to fire from predicting
Belgium to win that type of thing and as
a result I have to pass the data into it
that looks like that so when I pass the
data in for like you know these are the
players this is the form you know this
is the how they play in a certain
temperature in a certain field all of
those kind of data when I pass in the
answer then I also want the answer to be
you know one zero zero zero when it's
England were good zero one zero zero
when it's Belgium are good those kind of
things so that's the pattern for the
neuron that I want so this process and
like this is just one concept this is
called one hot encoding but this is part
of the process of feature engineering so
as a software developer intensive load
these are the type of terms and these
are the type of concepts that you need
to learn so that you can design your
data you can engineer the features of
your data so that you can train neural
networks around it so I want to give a
quick look at feature engineering in
Python so we can switch back to the demo
machine so the best thing to do I would
say is if you go to tensorflow org slash
tutorials this website teaches you how
to get started with tensor flow and if I
scroll down here these five links basic
classification text classification
regression overfitting under fitting and
saving and loading these will lead you
to something called a collab notebook
and the collab notebook looks like this
and what's really neat about the collab
notebook is that it's something that
executes completely in the browser but
it gives you the full tensorflow runtime
and it gives you the full tensorflow
code and api and you can even run it on
a GPU if you want to do training on a
GPU which is more optimized for and this
is something runs in the browser and is
completely free and what we've done is
we built these number of tutorials that
will say for example in this tutorial is
like if I want to do a binary
classification around movie reviews
there's all the code in there and allows
you to step through that code and it
will do things like such as the feature
engineering that I've mentioned here
it's preparing the data here is building
the model here is putting in the last
off to the lost function those kind of
things and it this will take you through
all the steps of like here's a raw feed
of data from IMDB and what we're going
to do with this raw feed of data from
IMDB is we're going to build
classification of good movie good movie
vs bad movie and I'll take you through
the steps of doing that so time is a
little short so I won't go through those
steps now but all of this is public and
it strongly recommends to go take a look
at their and step through these
notebooks it doesn't take long and
you'll find them all on tensorflow org
slash tutorials okay if we can switch
back to the slides please so the next
step remember was purring your data was
the first step preparing your data was
the second the thirst the next step and
the most important from a programmatic
step from a programmatic point of view
is training your models so first of all
when you're training your models there's
three different types of chip that you
can use in your computer we're all
familiar with the CPU and a CPU to me is
like a Swiss Army knife it's a chip
that's been designed to handle
everything in your computer managing
your windows managing your network stack
all of these kind of stuff your code
compiles and it executes on that so as a
result it's a general-purpose chip for
doing just about anything so therefore
it's not optimized for any one
particular thing it's just like a Swiss
Army knife the second type of chip is a
GPU and a GPU is kind of interesting
because it's a graphics processing unit
the graphics processing unit they've
evolved greatly for games over the over
recent years but the things that you do
in a game such as 3d rotation in the
matrix multiplication for that all that
kind of stuff is actually very similar
to the math that you would do in a
neural network if you remember earlier I
was talking about the math and
calculating the weights it's very very
similar to the kind of things that are
done in a GPU and of course the GPU is a
type of chip that's got lots of little
cores and all of these little cores are
optimized for doing math and as a result
for a long time the researchers who've
been trying to optimize what they're
getting out of machine learning have
been using GPUs and it's a chip that
works really great but it's not designed
for the task like slicing a chili pepper
with a razor blade and so then the third
one is a TPU and the TPU is a chip that
we've built and we've made available
it's called a tensor processing unit so
Tifa tensor with the idea being that
this is absolutely optimized for machine
learning it's optimized for processing
tensors and as a result it's like a
specialized knife like a sushi knife in
this case so this is a TPU and some of
the numbers behind it we get about a 180
teraflops per device
with memory 64 gig the reason for that
high bandwidth memories when you think
about loading data processing data
loading data so it really improves your
data throughput it's programmed via
tensorflow and it's now available in
beta so if you use the Google cloud
platform you can get a machine in the
Google cloud platform that uses a TPU
and then you can just rent time on that
CPU to do your training and like one
example that we've done was there's an
image classification thing called ResNet
where the as you can see here we did a
throughput of taking real images to
train and ResNet we were able to with a
10 to flow 1.7 about two and a half
thousand images per second with a TPU
but then when we pre process those
images to make them a little bit more
optimal that went up to a 30 150 you
know per second being able to process on
a CPU but the important one is bullet
point here is the third one that the
resonance you know for many years
researchers have been working on this
and to train a model and ResNet used the
cost in the tens of thousands of dollars
and then in the thousands of dollars and
then in the hundreds of dollars and we
did this one benchmark back in March
where we actually tested it was about 85
dollars in CPU time and I was actually
working on this slide it was used in our
keynote or the tensorflow summit that
Jeff Dean gave and as we were working on
the slide they came back and said
they've actually slashed it even further
but they haven't verified by how much
exactly but I'm not allowed to say the
number but it's significantly lower than
this so we have a kind of a Moore's law
in effect for the actual cost for
training where it's plummeting
dramatically and using tensor using GPUs
in particular even though TPU might be
on a per second basis more expensive
than a GPU when you can do that much
more with it and train a model much
cheaper and if you go to this URL at
Stanford you'll see their first
benchmark submission that we put around
it so then the next part is actually
using the models so you've gathered your
data you've processed your data you've
trained your model how do you use them
and so I'm very passionate about mobile
and using mobile but there's three
different things three different ways
that you can use machine learning models
so first of all is what I've been
talking about it's tensorflow tensorflow
itself it's designed so that you can
train models there's an API for you to
train models and it's a runtime for you
to execute them on your machine but you
know what if you've trained a model and
you've got a nice big fat GPU under your
desk you
train the model than that and you can
execute you can in fare on that so what
not anybody else can use the model right
it's great if you're an academic and
you're researching and you want to show
that hey I use this machine and I have
this model and here's my benchmark but
it's not very good for you to deploy the
model for other people to use so we've
been hard at work to build two runtimes
the first of these is tensorflow light
where the idea is that if you have an
Android device or an iOS device and an
increasing amount of IOT devices you've
probably seen we'd put demos out for
Raspberry Pi where the idea is like if
you got a Raspberry Pi device you can
then run inference on those devices and
by that I mean you build the model on
your big fat GPU under your desk or you
build it on a CPU and then you can
actually crunch that model flatten it
prepare it for mobile and then deploy it
to a mobile device and then on that
mobile device you do not need any
connection to the Internet to be able to
run inference on the model I have a
video that I'll show later if we have
time but it's a terrific example of
there's a crop in Africa well it's crop
all over but it's a it's used it's part
of the food group in Africa called
cassava and we worked with a group in
the country of Tanzania where cassava
was primarily the backup plant for
farmers they had their primary plants
that they wanted to grow but they had
cassava if their primary plan failed so
if the primary plan failed you wouldn't
have a famine but if the cassava failed
it's a disaster and the thing about
cassava that's really interesting is
that you know there is a disease there's
a blight that affects cassava but you
don't see this with the human eye until
it is too late you'll see splotches on
the leaves it's too late by that point
the plant is blighted and the blight has
spread to the other plants you just
don't see it yet so as a result of light
coming in the cassava can actually
destroy an entire crop before you know
it's been destroyed so we worked with a
university and we worked with some folks
in Tanzania to build a detector to say
you know to Train it on leaves and say
okay this is a leaf we don't know if
it's disease or not but in the future
we'll label it if that plant becomes
diseased and train it on a bunch of
these and it ended up being able to spot
on a disconnected device most
importantly it's a disconnected device
so no broadband connectivity that
farmers can take an old Android device
wave it over a leaf and determine much
earlier than you could with the human
eye if the leaf is diseased or not and
if it is diseased then they can yank
that plant out before it destroys the
rest of the crop
so little scenarios like that have been
empowered using this kind of thing train
it you're labeling you're giving the
data you're creating a model you're
flattening flattening that model and
then using tensor flow light you can run
it on a an Android device or an iOS
device and then the third of these is
tensor flow j/s and this one to me is
also particularly exciting because now
you can use javascript in the browser
not just to run inference on existing
models but to actually build the models
so although those steps that I was
talking about are gathering your data
preparing your data training the model
and running the model can be done
directly within a browser so think about
the distributed scenarios that are
available there if you go to youtube.com
slash tensorflow we got a lot of videos
on there and I'm actually in the middle
of producing a video series at the
moment on doing this in JavaScript so if
you're a JavaScript developer like the
basics of getting up and running with
creating a neural network training and
doing inference in the browser around
there so go take a look at them so I'm
going to switch back to tense flow light
for a second which is the mobile one
that I was talking about so the idea of
how that works is you've built your
model using your big fat GPU or your CPU
and then we've created a converter for
that so that with the process that I
called flattening that converts it to
tensorflow light formats and then
there's an interpreter that we've built
for iOS and other one for Android
another one for IOT devices that will
then execute that model for you and
depending on the hardware that you're
using then there are a hardware
acceleration delegates so more recent
Android phones for example are able to
use some of the hardware acceleration
delegates that are on there things such
as the pixel two so you can have even
faster inference on those we've also
tried to make it cross-platform as much
as we could so that converted to TF
light formats you know will convert it
so can be run on an android app using
java Kotlin or c++ on an iOS app only
using c++ at the moment we haven't yet
built the extensions to allow
objective-c or Swift to be used and then
also on linux and some other iot devices
and there's among going stuff on there
and some announcements coming pretty
soon about that to watch out for there's
some really exciting stuff happening in
IOT and if you're an iOS developer and
you want to use core ml then of course
you can use that too we've created a
converter to core ml format so you can
go off and use Swift or objective-c on
core ml once you've built your modeling
able to convert it one of the neat
things that we always get asked about is
the size what impact is this gonna have
on my Android device you know well we
found that the core interpreter to
interpret a model is about 75 kilobytes
now tensive low-light is in the very
early stages right now so in the early
stage is what we've done is we've built
it and we've optimized it for a number
of scenarios in the first scenario that
we've been working on is image
classification so there's a lot of the
common image classification models all
of the operations that they use are
currently supported so if you train
something like for example with mobile
net or ResNet and then you convert that
to tents flow light it will work but if
you train something custom that isn't
those like for example my breast cancer
classifier then that neural network
might use some operations that are not
supportive and so what current we're
continuing to work on having operational
support parity between tensor flow and
sensor Flo lights but right now with all
supported apps on tents Flo light it's
about 400 kilobytes ok let me give a
quick demo of image recognition on
mobile so this will be image recognition
if we can switch to the demo machine and
I'm going to run this on an Android
emulator so which is a little bit risky
so I'm just running a Miami later here
right now what this is doing is that
this is capturing from the camera on the
front of my laptop which is emulated as
the camera on the front of an Android
device and it's taking each frame and
it's passing that through a network
that's been trained to classify a
thousand different images so the output
from that network is going to be a
thousand different numbers with each
number being a probability that what
you're looking at is the thing
represented by that number like I think
for example number 55 is a coffee cup
those type of things
so of those thousand now it's looking at
the dots behind me here and it's
classifying that as like a shower
curtain or a window screen or a strainer
which is pretty good but I'm gonna do my
banana demo so it's I'm just gonna hold
this up because it sometimes gets a
little confused and if I hold this in
front of it can never know the
orientation there we go
you see it's actually well it was a
banana
there we go 76% chances have been our
syringe wow I don't know why I thought
that's this arrangement my favorite is I
usually stand in front of it and gives
me something different I was an Italian
Greyhound earlier I don't know why must
be my hair there we go
I'm a strainer you know so but thinking
about what's going on there there's a
thousand different things remember
already I was talking about cats versus
dogs right that was two different things
but here there's a thousand different
things the model for this is just a few
hundred kilobytes you know it's running
that because it's been flattened to run
on Android and it's just a simple
Android application that's reading a
frame from the camera passing that frame
to the model getting the array back from
the model of the thousand things picking
the top three figuring out what those
top three are and then showing it on the
screen and then that number is the time
of inference so you can see it's about
thirteen fourteen hundred milliseconds
but that's because it's running in the
emulator okay I have my pixel two phone
with me if you want to see a demo of it
later on a phone you'll actually see it
doing this classification and usually
thirty or forty microseconds it's that
fast of being able to do it the code for
this is completely open-source that's on
tensorflow dog go have fun have a play
with it there's also there's some code
labs outside there's one code lab called
tensorflow for poets which will teach
you all about this and how you can
retrain this to classify your own things
like maybe you want to classify
different types of flower or something
along those lines instead of the
thousand classes that it gives you and
it will show you how to do that so if we
can switch back to my slides
okay so tensorflow das is the next one
and so if we think about tensorflow das
the idea would sense flow digest as i
mentioned is that you can train a neural
network using javascript and you can
then run inference on that neural
network using javascript now i've been
talking about javascript in the browser
as one scenario but there's a second
scenario of your javascript program and
that's JavaScript on nodejs so if you
have a nodejs server that server can be
used to run inference for you or that
server can be used to gather data and
train things and where that to me gets
particularly exciting is any firebase
fans here a few cool so you're probably
familiar with something called cloud
functions for firebase
the nice thing about cloud functions for
firebase is that they are serverless
environments that you can write code on
and then that code will execute in
response to triggers so there can be
triggers in your application like maybe
a user logging in or a particular
analytics event happening and then code
could execute but now instead of
traditional javascript if-then code
executing that javascript could wrap a
model and then you could run inference
on that model maybe to do a
classification or something along those
lines
so that's like tensorflow das and if I
take a little bit and look at the code
again before I show a demo
just remember the ML paradigm it's all
about answers in data in and rules out
if you take nothing else away from this
as a programmer
start thinking in those terms start
thinking about what scenarios am I going
to get if I put answers in and I put
data in and I get rules out and I'm
going to give one final demo of that and
this one is a tough demo so let's see if
we can switch to the demo machine
alright so so this is a public demo if
you want to try it out for yourself it's
on jst tensorflow org and this is
pac-man so if you like me if you like
Google Doodles if you remember there was
a Google Doodle where we actually
created a pac-man maze out of the Google
logo so what this demo does is in the
browser you can see here there are four
boxes corresponding to up down left and
right so what I can do is I can start
capturing images of me
maybe pointing up or looking up or
something along those lines and I'm
actually going to start doing that now
I'll do it by pointing so I'm going to
start capturing some images are pointing
up you know move it around a little bit
because they all look a little bit
different
I don't know having the dotted
background if that's gonna ruin it or
not we'll see so about 80 of them and
I'm going to capture some images of me
pointing right get about 80 of them as
well down is always the hard one I'm
gonna catch some images of me pointing
down maybe I can't see how many of them
cuz it scrolled off I'll just guess it's
about 80 okay and I'm gonna capture
images of me pointing to the left try to
get my head out of the frame maybe and
remember this is all just running in the
browser I'm using the webcam on my
machine capture a bunch of them okay so
now I'm going to train the model so when
I train the model B
after I press the button you'll see a
number underneath which is the loss so
what that's doing is if you remember
earlier when I was showing it's
calculating something figuring it out
comparing it with the results seeing how
well it did seeing it did really badly
try something else and keep going and so
we'll keep going and you'll see the loss
should keep reducing so they're now the
loss is bad it's going down down down so
now the loss is really tiny so that's
telling me that of all the frames that
I've captured very very it's built a
model where it can predict like 99.999%
accuracy it thinks that if I give it a
frame of what that is so let's put that
in action and try playing pac-man so I'm
going to play and I'm gonna point to the
right come on pac-man there he's going
to the right I'll point up he's going up
oh yeah down down down
Oh what's this hand I use wasn't it down
there we go
I forgot I changed hands and now a fight
ah you got me
but even you'll see the highlights if
you don't look if you look at the
highlight on the images itself and
you'll see it's actually detecting
there's a right this is hard because I
have to switch hands you know that kind
of thing and there's a down let's come
on go left pac-man eat there we go
whoops I'm gonna die quickly switch Oh
too late
you know as you can see here this is
just this is entirely open source if you
want to play with the code yourself we
can switch back to slides please you
know so the what I've done here is I
just captured those images live I
trained the model with those images in
the browser you can see it only took a
few seconds to get it's a reasonable
accuracy and then we ended up being able
to play pac-man really badly okay so
finally then the last part to think
about and particularly thinking about
the future now is a real-world machine
learning system is all this stuff that
I've been talking about building models
and all that kind of thing is that tiny
little box in the middle when it comes
to production so when it comes you know
to be honest at an industry we're still
like in the infancy there's still lots
of opportunity out there and our ML code
that we build is that little box in the
middle there's all these other things
that you're going to need and I'm going
to focus on the ones on the right here
which are the serving infrastructure and
monitoring so if you want to build
something that's production ready of
course you need a serving infrastructure
that allow you to do it at scale you
need
trying to make sure you're doing it
right and all that kind of stuff and so
I would recommend you go take a look at
tensorflow serving so we've just just a
few weeks ago we released tensorflow
serving the idea it's a server
infrastructure for deploying models and
allowing people to access your models
via the web in a scalable and secure way
and the idea is that it keep your
traditional server architecture keep
your traditional request response
request response model if the the demo
that I just showed of pac-man that
actually downloaded an existing model
mobile net model of image classification
and then I retrain the final layer for
those four classes but the original
model that was downloaded that does most
of the work was something that got
served to me out of tensorflow serving
and as a result I can you know I can
actually be able to deploy that model
and retrain it as we just did so take a
look at TF serving for that so with that
you know this is the theme that we're
working on for tensorflow we're all
about really trying to make machines
intelligent and improve people's lives
we've open sourced this so that you can
build on it think of the scenarios that
you couldn't previously do as a
programmer think of the things that you
can't do with if-then code and you may
be able to do that with data in answers
in and being able to infer rules out so
with that I just want to say thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]